welcome everyone thank you very much for
joining this presentation
i will give you uh an update on the work
that we've done on opening technology
this last
year two years um starting with a short
introduction
and that introduction i usually start
with uh with this this slide
that indicates where we think the organo
technology uh has its impact where we
think the overall technology contributes
to drug development
and it is basically this um
problem that of course everyone in drug
development knows that when we
do our pre-clinical work and the models
we use animal models cell lines
are useful to show biological function
uh
but in the end when we look at clinical
trials or or used
or the drug use in the in the market uh
we find that
as as as is understandable that these
models are not patients and therefore
are not predicting very well what the
patient response will be like
and it will be like when we actually use
it on a large on large groups of
people and this leads to this relatively
inefficient
drug development strategies that that we
are used to
expensive drugs whereas we think that if
you
improve the pre-clinical models if we
can improve the patient
patient representation in the
pre-clinical drug development we would
significantly increase
the efficiency of drug development and
thereby decreasing costs
um organoids fit exactly in this step
because
also why we call it patient and lab
because what we do with organoids is
basically we can take
samples from patients and directly put
it into the lab to do our research on
and that all started with the discovery
of this
adult stem cell more than 10 years ago
by now
in the lab of hans clavers this
discovery of an of the adult stem cell
initially on the intestine and then
other organs
allowed us to isolate this cell and to
try to understand it better and to see
if we could find means
to take this particular cell and expand
it in vitro
and this is indicated on this slide you
see in the left top corner
that we can start with single cells or
as we now
do in in the lab on the tissue fragments
but initially with single cells to make
the point that indeed
when we take out this single adult stem
cell and we provide it with the right
information with our growth factors we
can expand the cell
unlimited and very importantly with
keeping its
genetic stability so this is the problem
with the cell lines of course that when
we grow it in the lab
we get the adaption to the culture
the culture conditions and thereby this
genetic and also epigenetic
modifications basically mean that the
cell that we're growing in the lab is no
longer
the patient cell and thereby although it
is
it is useful to identify biological
function it doesn't
necessarily mean that the responses are
like
our patient like so the interesting
thing in in in this
in this method um is that indeed when we
go see osato in the lab when he was able
to take this stem cell and to expand it
we not only got a lot of stem cells but
we in fact got a structure
that is you see it here it's a little
bit of a fumbled up intestine
but what it is if we look at it
microscopically is a a real
epithelial barrier of an intestine where
the luminal side of the intestines on
the inside of the organoid and the
outside of the opioid is the basal
membrane of the
of the intestine and that also goes for
other organs if we use lung or
breast or other tissues that works in
exactly the same way
that the luminal sides are inside and
the other side is on the outside of the
opinoid
and the cells in the organoid have stem
cells differentiated cells
function and communicate together as if
there are a normal epithelium
so with this in combination with what i
already said
the genetic stability we now have a
culture system
that has a resemblance functional
resemblance
to normal tissue while maintaining this
genetic stability on the long term
because another very important quality
is that
with this method we can expand these
cells virtually unlimited depends a
little bit in the organ
but without having the intestine here
so we can generate biobanks we can
generate reservoirs of these cells
that can last us as cell lines do for uh
for an indefinite amount of time and
thereby we can capture patients long
term
we can capture the heterogeneity of
different patients
and we can study these stably over over
an extended period of time
so these uh that was the that is by now
10 years ago so this is a set we started
with the intestine
and having these intestinal stem cells
we then
started working on other organs and the
epithelial systems epithelial stem cells
turned out to be fairly similar between
cell types
between transporting organs so this
means that
with these intestinal system we could
later on develop also lung
liver pancreas organs that you see
represented in this in this video
importantly we can take when we talk
about cancer organic healthy tissue in a
diseased tissue as you see here cancer
and healthy
which basically means that we can
generate an internal control of patients
and we can expand these cells cancer
stem cells now in this case
stem cells and the normal and the normal
healthy cells
indefinitely we then characterize these
cells
genetic characterization of course
genetic being the basis of most of the
work that we're doing in the lab
um is added onto the system but
and that is the the important organoid
attribute
uh we now have a functional and live a
living cell so we can do functional
experiments all these
on all these patients so we can combine
basically what we know from before
genetics clinical data with functional
data on its organ and see
the patient-specific drug responses
so that was the key to the to the organo
technology
and the basis of it a couple of years
ago
of course there's this claim that that
the organoids are indeed a model that is
closer to patients and to be supported
because
we understand all that a key aspect of
clinical work
is that we want to have a model system
that is patient like however we need to
prove that
and the and an important part of
organoids is that indeed now you can
um whereas in the past genetics or other
data
are indirectly related to potential
patient outcome
outcomes what we can do with an organoid
because we isolate
tissue fragments from individual
patients while they're in the in the
in the treatment process while they're
in the hospital we can take these
samples you can see that here for an
example of
breast cancer so you can take an
organoid sample an organoid
and a biopsy you can generate an
organoid from this biopsy
we characterize that in the lab that
does genium sequencing
and drug drug screenings etc basically
any sort of technology that we generally
use in them
and then we can take those organoids and
you see that here in the left bottom
and we can test different patients for
instance the patient here is presented
in green and one represented in red
and we test the drugs that are also used
on these same patients
in the clinic and what we find is that
indeed
and that the importance to the and the
previous claim that is it basically
represent
is it mimicking patient responses what
we see is that there is in green and
basin samples
organic samples that are responding very
well to this hormone treatment whereas
we see in red patients that are not
responding
and now when we go back to the clinic
what we see is that
also when we look at the same patient
from which we took this biopsy from
which we generate these opinoids
we see that that same therapy that we
use in lab responses are the same so
we see in green the patient that in the
clinically responded version right we
have a patient that did not respond
i think this is the key to to organize
experiments the way
that that help is generating owners but
also the way other
labs academic and and commercial labs
are
generating the the 21st century models
let's say
that indeed this is for the first time
this type of work is possible so
now we can take patient specific samples
use them in the lab
and have a direct correlation between
what is happening in the lab and what's
happening in the clinic
and and this is the i think that the
basics of how we can
use these these new models in the future
for drug development
knowing that we should actually when
doing our pre-clinical work
we should try to make this direct
connection and use it as if
we are looking at an example in the
clinic so i have some this is summarized
here so
basically meaning that traditionally
we've had clinical data a molecular
dietary on the left
with organoid data we basically add a
functional test to each
to each laboratory experiment and to
each patient
that we can use to combine the clinical
side of our work to the pre-clinical
side of our work and use it
either in identifying biomarkers basis
stratification drug development
but even in potential diagnosis
support so predictive diagnostic testing
to determine what patients
what type of treatment patients might
need
that's what i wanted to uh to show you
as an
as an example as an introduction and
this is the basis i think this is also
what
has to come back in these in this model
development in our field
that we constantly consider when we are
generating nice biological systems do
they in fact
represent what is the patient and that
can now be
validated so it's important to do that
in this graph you see what that means so
now we have on the one hand shown that
when we have an organoid we see that
these responses in a large spot
represent what happens in the patient
so when i have a cohort of patients in
the lab organoids
and i use in this case for example four
different treatments that are used in
the treatment of colon cancer
i can have an assumption of how these
patients would respond in the clinic
so you see indeed that when you take
here in the different colors
five of you for instance um that we see
this range of drug responses as expected
in the clinic also back in the organized
and that basically goes forward to do
the four treatments that are represented
here
the different patients show a different
response and that you see this
heterogeneity
responses among patients as we as we
expect in the clinic
so um that is an introduction so what i
wanted to show you is that
with this we have developed different
models and also what
is an important aspect at the moment
that as already discussed on the one
idea of this clinical validation
on the other hand i showed you this
initial organo this
sort of 3d cystic structure that
represents epithelium
that is the the basics as i'd say the
first type of organoid that we can use
for
especially viability screening drug
screening as i showed you
however for certain other disease
diseases or interaction with the immune
system
we need to develop new organoid models
that
other ways of representing the
epithelial barrier and those are the
examples
that i want to show you today
so this is an example of lung which is
where the
initial sort of 3d organoid is capable
of already showing you quite a lot of
phenotype in this case we are
representing the cystic fibrosis
as a physical fibrosis phenotype because
what you can see here is that in the
normal
the normal open right here um this
is a in in this is not a video but if
you would look in the video you see the
cilia present but also beating
but what you see on the bottom is that
we have a healthy organoid and
an ominous cystic fibrosis patient and
as expected and as seen
in a cystic fibrosis patient is a very
thick mucous layer
present in the cystic fibrosis
airway orbinoid variant that is absent
in the normal organ
so you see that these organelles
represent on the one hand
the genetics and the genetic stability
but also the phenotypic characteristics
that we see into
several diseases can be represented as
here with the
with the uh with the secretion of this
uh of this very thick mucus
that we know from cystic fibrosis
here's another example that in part by
the labs of the erasmus university and
clevis
um using the organelles in bowel
infection of course very relevant at the
moment
on the right we see an older example
from sucks
where he used these lung organoids to
study rsv infections
this is an important one because that
indicates that the gene expression again
in the organoids is
as it is in vivo because cell systems
are often difficult to recapitulate
viral infection because
the gene expression the protein
expression on the membrane is not
sufficient
to support viral expansion whereas here
you can see that indeed we connect
we can infect along overnight with rsv
and we have a
stable long-term reflection of these
rapid
replicating virus in these in these
organisms in fact when we use a specific
antibody that blocks
the uptake of the of the virus we see
indeed
on the right here that the gfp in the
right
is absorbed in the normal overnight but
when we add the antibody the
rsv gfp level rf is not taken up by the
overnight
and on the left of course the very
relevant uh example at the moment is
that indeed you can use in this case
intestinal organoids
to study uh for instance uh corona
infections as well
and uh as i was shown in this study
earlier last year uh by
the glavors and the grouping rather than
so
i think the importance of this is other
than that we can use it for fire
infections is that it is an indication
again
that organoids have gene expression
patterns that are very similar or are
similar
to normal healthy tissue and therefore
are
can be used for studying a range of
biological functions for instance
viral infections another important one
is that we often use as an example in
toxicology whereas which is another
pre-clinical field in which the healthy
systems is
healthy cells are of course very
important but also very important is
that
there is natural mature gene expression
in in the systems
which is sometimes absence for instance
when we look at embryonic derived stems
or
rest the right cells in this case
because we are working with an adult
stem cell
we can generate these mature cells both
stem cells but also differentiate cells
as i i'm going to show you
another important point is that the
organoids have actually the first
coconut rods developed from a mouse and
before we went to develop the human
system
um it was ecology of course a lot of
animal species are still being used
what we've seen in our experiments is
that the organoids from these animals
for instance many people derive
organoids or dark derived organics
share the same phenotypes as we as we
see in the animals themselves
similar to what we see the clinical
representation of human organelles of
course
so that means that for these particular
toxicology studies we can use animal
derived organoids
human derived organoids put them
together
and have a a more complete picture based
also on historic data that is often
animal derived to basically assess the
safety of specific compounds
and on the right and important because
we have much more freedom
to choose which type of organelle we
need as opposed to cell lines that are
just
sometimes randomly derived and and when
it works
um we can develop organelles from
different parts of intestinal colon or
other organs
because we know that gene expression
therefore safety with toxicology
responses are different
in different regions of organs um so
i'll just
again give you some examples so in this
case
we started two molecules and this
molecule here on the right we can
be called abbreviation um so this in
this case what we use
is a different animals dog and the reds
and then comparing it to human
and the key point here is that what we
see and
known for this particular molecule is
that we see
a viability response that is the
viability testing
that is representative for what we have
seen in the in people and
animals as well so where here we have a
compound that seems relatively uh it's
not
it's quite toxic in the dark and the red
berries we see that in humans is
actually not very toxic at all
so when we test these the animal models
in the lab in a preclinical phase we
actually are maybe given the wrong
message because
the fitness is not as old as toxic in
the human samples as it is in the animal
samples
whereas when we look at this particular
molecule we see the reverse
and we see that although it is quite
toxic in the red
it is uh it is much less toxic in human
i'm saying this the wrong way around
here so indeed we see here that the
human sample is quite toxic and the
animal cells are animal
samples were not whereas here we see
that the
toxicity seen in the red varies we see
that it's
largely absent in the human sample so
basically
what it tells us is that we can use
these animal uh organoids
but also therefore the human organoids
to get a better picture
and a picture that is often screwed when
we use animal models
because of the difference in the species
another important point is that as i
alluded to earlier is that this is done
when we use the 3d type of overnight
but but for many type of assays it's
actually easier to have
to have it in a normal as in the
intestine itself
access to the different sides of the
membrane so we
developed also the same orbital
structure on the in a 2d
in a 2d system so transverse-like system
something i didn't talk about before but
based the
media conditions based on the growth
factors that we are adding
you can steer the differentiation of the
overnight towards stem cells or towards
the different differentiated cells
as you can see here uh that we're
changing from this to this for instance
we see
the expression of nuisance
which is absent in this type of media
where we focus more on stem cells
so basically in the colon and in the
intestine
by using different media and different
setups
of the of the systems that we use we can
gear the model towards
whatever experimental needs or our
biological means we need
we need to study and you see an example
here then for about that what that means
so we use these uh media steer at the
transwell systems or
as in the previous slide for the
materials to basically measuring electro
electric conductance over the membrane
which means that if that
is if the membrane is disturbed for
instance that happens in
ibd inflammatory biologists that uh
that in that case the the the resistance
of the membrane obviously decreases
and you can see that here we mimic the
the inflammation phenotype of the
disease
by adding cytokines and so in the in
black we see that we have a membrane
that's intact that has full barrier
function
but when we increase the cytokines that
we that we can see
in an inflamed intestine we see that
indeed
this causes the barrier function of the
of the membrane to be lost
uh here by the decreasing already
increasing our decreasing resistance
increasing
over this membrane and then
interestingly on the right
if we use a particular compound that
inhibits this phenotype as we know from
the from the clinic
we can restore the barrier so basically
here we introduce in the
in the graph uh to the bottom the high
concentration of the that we found on
the left of the cytokines
and when we add tofacetine then we can
restore the barrier function of this of
this
intestinal organoids so basically with
this we mimic
we mimic the inflammation and we can
study compounds that that actually
restore
barrier function in the in the intestine
and this is i said there's something
that we use for ibd this is an example
of that so indeed
when we use when we want to study
inferential biologists we can
isolate organoids from uh as you see in
the middle panel
from tissue itself you see the inflamed
colon tissue and then
next to it in a normal tissue and
generate organic from both
we see gene expression to be different
indeed in these two regions of course as
we know
some of this is lost in time because
when the information goes in the culture
system
also a part of that inflammatory
signature goes
however other parts of it are are more
stable and you will see long term in the
organize
so with this by taking different regions
and said in the beginning and by taking
different regions
of the intestinal colon other organs of
course
we can study the specifics of that of
that region and
also in the case of this inflammation in
inflammatory disease
we can take inflamed uh region organisms
and
and healthy uh relatively at least
and non-inflamed sections of the
intestine and make organs above to do
comparisons
so with it on the and another important
organ
and when we talk about the maturation
of cells for toxicology studies is the
liver of course
that was an important one for us also to
establish whether the organoids are
can be mature enough but with the see in
ips or
es derived hepatocytes in vitro is that
they
they don't reach the metabolic function
they don't read cytokine expression
as we see from normal hepatocytes so
what we did with the organelles and you
can see that here on the left panel
we create this expansion state in which
we
have mostly stem cells that are that are
growing and then
from that we go to a second system where
we differentiate them into a better size
and you can see that yeah
from seven to 15 days you get an
increasing expression of
in this example uh chip three and four
uh showing the maturation of the of
their petrocytes
and what is important on the on the
right is that we see again the
the expression of and this is actually
enzyme function this is an enzymatic
asset
of cytogram 3 and 4 but also to c9
so we have the different cytograms
expressed and in the bottom
um very importantly when we compare that
to donor petty sites
so peter sites that were derived
directly from the liver
we see that although with a short delay
we see
to the right of that graph that when we
look at in this case
metabolism basically the ultimate
readout of the
maturation and function of these
hepatocytes we see that we reach a level
that is very much the same between an
organoid derived a better side and then
what a normal donor derived her better
size
so very different from ips and es which
could be
much closer to the bottom when you look
at the
at this particular metabolism so indeed
we have uh
sites that are up to seemingly mature
and then what we can see if we test
again this is a viability essay
as an example when we test different
compounds uh that we know
from the clinic are toxic um so here we
have
in the blue and red two examples of
compounds that
were found to be toxic in the clinic and
test them on human organoids
and the interesting point is that these
were actually compounds where
initially in the pre-clinical studies it
was not discovered
that they that they had toxic effect but
indeed
with using human hepatocyte-derived
organoids
we can indeed detect this already
pre-clinically whereas actually the
other two compounds
also had some toxicity issues but their
immune system
dependent toxicity which in this
particular case although i'll come back
to it later
because we use a system that does not
include the immune system of course
we do not see any toxic effect when
using them here
so basically what this means is that we
have
these organoid systems uh that on the
one hand then we
started out with discussing cancer we
can
use viability test to test drug
responses in in
different tumors and in different
patients
and on the other side we have because of
these cells being human
being so close to patients when we use
the healthy cells we can use them for
toxicology studies but also studies of
inflammatory diseases like ibd or
genetic disease i didn't show that here
other than the cystic fibrosis example
but so cells that are relatively healthy
and normal genetically
and they can be grounded in their
differentiated cells and the stem cells
together
will provide us a good picture of what
the disease looks like
for the last bit of the of the
presentation i want to show the
um another recent example this is a
picture from unreals at the
prince's maxima center in the
netherlands showing the
culture system of t-cells and organoids
a very important one at the moment of
course because of the importance of
the the immune system in oncology and
the new drugs
that are actually treating this so what
we see here is in green and ovenoids
with
in this case targeting t cells that
killed these these organoids
um the point of this uh already a couple
of years old right
is that indeed it shows that we can
co-culture these cells
and then here are more important
pictures than when we use this this was
in in specifically
genetically manipulated t-cells where we
have
in these cells so that they target
indeed specific tumor cells on the top
we have a healthy organoid and as you
can see that hopefully
in the right top corner you see one
organoid that is not
targeted by these cells clearly um it's
a healthy cell so these these
critiques should not be targeting this
but now when we go to the bottom
um in this repeating image we see that
there yeah there's the healthy one again
the
enjoy the intact one but now the tumor
of the same patient and indeed it's
specifically killed so we see two things
here one that we can co-culture
organoids with
with the immune system to t cells and
show that the killing of these organoids
of these tumor cells by adt
cells but also that we can show this
difference between the healthy cells and
tumor cells
as and from the same patient importantly
so in this case we see
that the healthy cell of that same
person does not respond to the chief
university
and what does and you see that here in
the summary again
but then for a larger group so we
actually have on the left here in
imaging again
the top one patient in the tumor without
and with treatment
left and right and then next with normal
organoids in which they're not
responding to this
to these t cells and the bottom another
patient same thing so the tumor is
specifically killed that the healthy
cells are not
and then to the right and that i think
is an interesting point as well
so these are uh t cells that
from which genetically it can be assumed
that they should be able to target all
of the tumor cells of this particular
type
but what you see if we test a panel here
and represented by about 10 different
patients here with two different
books of black dots each small group of
black dots is one patient
and what we see that on the left we see
a group of patients
that is not responding and then we see
an increasingly good response
measured in this case by interfering
gamma secretion as an indirect measure
of the response
um so we see that that that under
that there's an increasing response of
the tumors to the t cell or actually
called
t cells to the tumor and then with the
open dots they're healthy
from comparison of the temptation not
responding so we do see these
heterogeneity responses whereas
although we wouldn't know the genetics
behind it we see
part of the patient not responding and
another part it is responding
so i think they said this is the point
and that is also summarized here so but
we now have now taking the organ of
technology again where we stand at the
moment
we have shown that for many
samples that we can generate these
disease models that are genetically
stable that
from a scientific perspective should
indeed represent the patients and indeed
when we do these comparisons to the
clinical studies to the clinical results
we see a direct correlation between
patients and tumor
whereas at the same time we can use and
then
we can use these samples in a group in a
biobank as i recover
not only from a single patient but in a
group we can have an idea
of what happens to the to a treatment
when we test it
with real tests in a clinical trial and
so this was
this picture indicates in a circle as
opposed to on the left a more
traditional development
from chemical chemistry to cell lines to
animal models to clinical trials which
leads to this failure to respond and
cause
any inefficiency in the development of
drugs because
more in the circle we can now connect
the patients to the pre-clinical work we
basically
have a system that allows us to test
both clinically and preclinically
the same type of patients the same
patient group and it allows us
to integrate the data but also hopefully
to much more efficiently develop
develop these develop new treatments so
thank you very much that is what i
wanted to show you today of the work
that we've done at the hub and it's here
in this particular
beautiful building here in the sun thank
you very much
and
you